[Applaudissements]
merci Sébastien oui la Fédération de la
Vienne est prête comme toutes les autres
fédérations nous sommes prêts à
accueillir tous les nouveaux- venus
alors bien sûr depuis 2012 nous avons
connu des épreuves mais nous sommes
aujourd'hui nous les militants fin prêt
on l'a démontré dans la Vienne comme
partout ailleurs la victoire municipale
départementale sénatoriale c'est aux
militants que nous la devons merci à eux
nous devons aussi être prêt et nous
sommes prêts parce qu'au fond François
Hollande abîme le pays et 2017 nous
avons pas le choix c'est le sursaut ou
le déclin 2017 c'est l'occasion
historique peut-être la dernière de
redresser le pays dans mon département
la Vienne François Hollande et ses amis
abîment les territoires pas un mois qui
passe sans que des entreprises ou des
suppressions d'emploi soient annoncéon
fédéral mul et moi je me souviens qu'à
l'inverse en 2011 un autre président de
la République Nicolas Sarkozi était venu
à châel r sauver l'effondererie du
Poitou et 400 emplois et qu'aujourd'hui
cette usine se bat sur le marché mondial
pour avoir des culasses Renault et pour
continuer à vivre à faire vire 400
familles voilà la différence les
socialistes sont passifs nous nous
sommes engagés pour l'emploi nous sommes
prêts enfin parce que les Français sont
prêts à tourner la page de François
Hollande ils sont prêts à nous entendre
ne les decevons
faisons en sorte que nous puissions être
à leur écoute avec un projet avec des
programmes incarnons l'alternance d'ors
et déjà alors oui aujourd'hui c'est une
belle journée on était impatient de se
retrouver nombreux ici le 30 mai et
j'espère qu'on sera nombreux à dire dans
plusieurs mois plusieurs années j'étais
là le 30 mai c'est là que tout a
commencé nous sommes prêts vivre les
républicains en
avant